you know why I'm number 11 son is  because I'm number one two times [ __ ]  I'll take this y'all know why number  level 1 times 1  it's always 1 you know I'm saying all  your Facebook friends do I have to find  my lunch where's the lines you know what  this with my bring me lines just  [ __ ] I'm very intelligent David he  just takes me for granted are we a good  couple  telogen like then she wants me to be  behind them I wouldn't be in front of  them  you know sometimes I want to be on top  like the bottom I'm not the woman in in  this relationship  I am the man  nuk nuk neck-and-neck in hook neck neck  and neck bone filling me i haven't came  in like couple weeks man i got a newborn  [ __ ] just got just got married man it's  crazy  thank you appreciate it like mizzu lines  i'm getting paper is going on the  internet